thanks Lucas for inviting me here and
the whole team it's an honor to be here
with you guys and share what we're doing
which is has been somewhat separate from
what the professors are doing and now
finally connecting so it's pretty
exciting my name is Jillian Bloomfield I
work for the environmental leadership
and training initiative LT which is one
of the academic programs as part of the
forestry school here at Yale and the for
the LT as a whole our program is a joint
initiative between Yale and the
Smithsonian and it started in 2006 as a
way to take the network and the
knowledge and all of the potential of
Yale and the Smithsonian and really
bring that it to the world trying to
address the need to build capacity on
environmental topics so we have our
program has a training program which
offers workshops and field courses and
other field based activities and
conferences and the participants who are
active in those field courses then
qualify for our leadership program which
helps bring them to the next level in
building their capacity to make change
happen on the ground and all of this has
happened since 2006 and then in six
years later in 2012 we started a
web-based program to complement not
replace the on-the-ground field program
so this like our field courses the
strategic objective of this program is
to help provide learning opportunities
to adults and are as per our donor
stipulation we are trying to Train
adults in Latin America and tropical
Asia and these are people who work for
NGOs for government nonprofits and are
not current students but rather
decision-makers and people influencing
change on the ground and the online
course enhances lt's program by building
a broader global audience right now we
can only offer five or six
courses field courses per year in those
regions and it and if the courses in
Columbia usually only Colombians can
come to the course so in this case we
can reach a broader audience and reach
people who would not be taking a week
off of work but couldnt integrate this
course into their normal work so when
first starting out going from having an
institution doing field courses and
thinking about how to translate that
into online courses we were kind of
surprised at the beginning of the even
formation of this program I have been
working for LT already for a year before
we started the online training program
and the big questions coming up or how
are we possibly going to treat teach
about the environment about tropical
forests online and so what we did
starting out was I put together this
report which was recalled a program
opportunities assessment so to start out
what I did was research what other
online programs are out there intended
for an international audience and also
addressing environmental or conservation
development topics so this is very
different than university of illinois
offering a course for credit to their
students this was looking at programs
with an international focus and usually
not for credit and then I I took a few
of the courses interviewed the different
instructors facilitators and overall got
an idea of what was going on and that
was back in 2012 and so much has changed
even since then um one of the things I
also did was send out to all of our
participants of past courses of survey
explaining our interest in online
learning and getting their feedback on
what we had planned and so a lot of
decision-making had to do with the
feedback of the in-person courses of
course participants and through all that
really came up with a starting place for
our courses that we would try to use a
portfolio different educational tools to
see kind of what worked and what didn't
work the magic thematic modules that
we're about one week each flexible hours
within the week so that they could have
their full-time jobs and do field work
and the other things environmental
practitioners do and then one of the
aspects that was really important was
why are they going to take this course
they're not just taking it because they
have free time there take the that we
want them to take it because the
homework can provide practical skills
that directly relate to their work and
serve as a professional development
opportunity and at the end of the course
they get a certificate of participation
so we had our first course it launched
in May 2013 and was repeated in
September 2013 and it's interesting we
started in Spanish and that was mostly
because a lot of the work I had already
been doing for LT was in Spanish so a
lot of the content was there were being
created and um in the audience as I
mentioned was focused on practitioners
not on students and the commitment was
about six hours of work per week for six
weeks we found out later that they ended
up spending around 10 hours of work per
week and the course is free of charge
which was not our decision that was part
of the donor of our whole programs
decision the course is divided into
weekly modules I won't get into the
specifics right now but basically we're
teaching a method to think a way of
thinking about an ecosystem and how you
can relate that to forest restoration so
what's the ecology of the site what's
the history of disturbance and how are
you going to use that to influence your
strategies for restoration so this is
restoring forest to de forested lands
and poor the interactive part for the
portfolio of course tools this one of
the things we did was we creative what I
called interactive presentations it's
almost like an interactive textbook but
for each module either myself or with
the help of student interns and all
reviewed by someone from our steering
committee or a guest expert with a
doctorate we created these five
synthesis of presentations to really
direct the course in the way that
you wanted and provide the background
information for each module then we had
pre-recorded lectures that we created to
complement each one of the synthesis so
in this case two of the pre-recorded
lectures were given by staff within LT
and the presentations were developed
within LT and it also served as a way
for three of the presentations to invite
guest experts including some of the
people on our steering committee
breathing's we used readings that we've
created such as the one on the end where
that's a conference proceedings that we
created internally and then readings for
externally as of now open content and
case studies which featured clear
examples on the ground that with
partners who with whom we worked with on
the ground and finally interaction with
people so they had interaction with each
other interaction with guest experts and
live video conferences and an
interaction with myself as the course
facilitator of teaching assistant and a
guest expert who reviewed all of their
final projects speaking of final
projects one of the things to make it
applicable on the ground to their work
was incorporating throughout the whole
course that each week they were working
towards the development of the final
project where they came to the course
with a specific site in mind in their
home country that they were evaluating
the ecology of that site evaluating the
history of disturbance evaluating the
strategies of restoration at what social
political factors they had to consider
and how they were going to do monitoring
and follow-up and all of that went
together to form what we called a
preliminary management plan so these
pictures just show one person's
preliminary management plan for a site a
deforested site in the Guanacaste region
of Costa Rica so it was neat at the end
of the course you have these management
plans many of which are already starting
to be implemented and that they're
sending to their supervisors or
potential donors and can do something
with so the course was in very high
demand we had no idea what to expect
and we received 375 applicants at the
beginning originally we hope to get
maybe 50 to then get a first cohort as a
pilot and we were shocked when all the
applicants started flowing in and we
only opened the applications between
april third and 19th this is the
breakdown between men and women and it
kind of shows you about about 200 were
not we were allowed to be super
selective we said no and then we really
wanted to take everyone else but we
couldn't for the first course because we
wanted to limit to 25 so that we could
really pilot the course or see how the
experience was going to go without the
overwhelming ourselves for the second
course instead of just opening it to
anyone we did a much more targeted
approach taking people from the waiting
list asking guests or partner
organizations for recommendations of
people and then opened it up for a
little window in which we still got 87
applicants and had to choose but for the
leftover spots this just shows you the
pretty faces of some of the participants
just to give an idea we had a range of
ages somewhat closer to younger people
but even going up to people in their 50s
and out of the ones accepted of the
first course 20 out of 25 received their
final certificate meaning they finish to
the end 24 out of 31 for the second
course so that's a much higher
percentage than MOOCs it's not as high
as we would like of course but we're
working with very international people
and usually the dropouts happened along
along the course and for various
different reasons one person said oh my
wife had appendicitis I can't keep up
with the course one person said due to
armed conflict in Columbia they can't
they can't they're at internet hasn't
been working for two weeks things like
that these are real problems that people
are facing this just shows you some of
the responses we had received very good
feedback from the course participants
and they really appreciate the idea that
they had these
this management plan that they could try
to work with and some of them said even
by the end of the course oh yeah I've
already talked to my supervisors we're
having a meeting about it next week our
future plans soon mark februari tent we
have a different course being offered
which is a more advanced course that
shorter and has more live component
which is a training for trainers of
forest restoration we're offering the
same course in Portuguese in March which
should be interesting because I'll take
a backseat as a current master student
from FES takes a more facilitator role
because he's a native portuguese speaker
and then where I'm working on a version
adapted for tropical Asia that would be
in English and then eventually an
English version that we could offer to a
paying audience in North America even
though it doesn't fit our donor goal it
could be in addition and use additional
support other course ideas advanced
monitoring of restoration projects
restoration finance and payments for
ecosystem services social political
drivers advanced techniques for
production productive lands these are
just some of the many possibilities and
the ideas all of this would build
towards eventually having a certificate
program where they take the intro course
and two or three electives and then get
a certificate whatever that means of
tropical forest restoration from the
environmental leadership and training
initiative and we also want to integrate
some of the online training with the
field based training we're thinking of
doing monitoring online where we can
incorporate some of the expertise of say
english-speaking yell professors for
monitoring as the with subtitles as the
prerequisite for then a field course in
Colombia and so thanks these are thank
you to the LT team and the office of
digital dissemination online learning
and all the people who have helped work
towards this
you